the the topic for this Workshop is anger
and this is a significant issue
um in our time but also in the time of
the ancient stomachs and they had a lot
to say about it it's quite useful and
I'll be drawing primarily on two stoic
thinkers Seneca and Epictetus and
particles they're the guys that we have
the most of uh come on in hi
um so my hope is that this proves useful
for you in your own you know path your
own work this is the stoic week event
for Milwaukee in part because I'm the
only person who was ready to put out a
stock week event so you may not be all
that interested in Anger maybe you're
more interested in stoicism but anger is
what you get because this is the
workshop that's put together for stoicon
so I thought I would I would provide it
here so what I I'd like to make a really
brief match and I'll introduce myself
very quickly right now I'm working on a
short Book Project hopefully it remains
a short Book Project
expanding on some of what we're going to
discuss here on stoic philosophy and
anger and hopefully it'll come out in
2017 published by by my company reason I
owe the reason I'm going to do that is
you know now that the onus against
self-publishing is gone uh we can make
things instantly accessible and
affordable in ways the big companies
don't unfortunately so I'm I'm Greg
Sadler I am a local philosopher and
content producer I do some Executive
coaching philosophical counseling as
well and the editor of stoicism today
which is which is why
um I you know
connected with the stoicism today and
stoic week
projects I can't actually call myself a
stoic in any sort of full sense because
I'm more eclectic I draw on the stomachs
for some things like with the anger but
also on aristotelians on you know you
know existential philosophy on a couple
other things as well so I'm like that
guy Cicero from whom we know a lot about
some of the earlier stoics he you know
he was kind of all over the map he'd
pick and choose on some things he'd say
the stocks are the best but other things
he'd say these other people over here
are the best I have found the stoics
myself very useful when it comes to
anger
in several different ways one is in sort
of a theoretical understanding of the
topic is probably the least interesting
another is in my own life I'm a person
who struggled a lot in the course of my
life with anger
and so I've used the stoics and some
other insights to help me with that and
I've also used it with clients quite
successfully because I think there's
there's really something there so what
we're going to do in this Workshop I
think what we might do just in interest
of time is
instead of talking about the common
experiences of angers if we move quickly
we'll probably skip over that I've got a
little passage I want to read you from
Epictetus we'll look at stoic analyzes
of anger as an emotion we'll look at
some techniques for dealing with your
own anger we'll look at some techniques
for how to deal with other people's
anger since we live in a society that
seems you know pretty shot through with
anger it's quite useful and then we'll
talk about practices and disciplines and
some the role of habit I've got a lot of
materials I'm going to you know throw
quite a bit at you but I also want to
have time for any q a at each point and
you know with a group this small I think
that we can actually just you know take
pauses whenever we need to and you know
to like raise your hand or anything just
just burst in I did save some time at
the end for for Q a and wrap up
um but you know maybe we'll use that up
before that so here is the passage I'd
like to read this is from book two of
epictetus's discourses
and he's talking about before this about
having sort of a Nat you know destroying
something in our self when we screw up
and he says um
am I not to injure the man who's injured
me that's one of the ways we get into
the dynamic of anger so he says well
first consider what injury is and call
to mind well you've heard the
philosophers say for if the good lies in
our faculty of choice and the evil like
likewise in there see if what you're
saying does not come to something like
this now think to yourself whether when
you're angry you've ever had this kind
of line of reasoning
well what then since so-and-so has
injured himself by doing me some wrong
shall I not injure myself by doing him
something wrong he says why then don't
we represent the case to ourselves in
such light as that
so what he's saying is you know when
when somebody does something that we
take to be an injury and we feel a sense
of anger typically that person has
screwed things up for themselves and
it's in a certain respect crazy for us
to think that well my way of getting
back at them is going to screw up is
going to be I'm going to screw myself up
so that I can get revenge on that and
that's that's the way a lot of our our
thinking work so we don't say it to
ourselves quite like that that's the way
a lot of our thinking works when we get
angry so how do the stoics view anger
um they one of the things that you can
say about that is as opposed to almost
everybody else in antiquity
the stoics had what you can call a zero
tolerance policy when it came to anger
doesn't mean that they never got angry
but they never said that it was a good
thing they viewed it as uniformly a bad
thing to get angry there was no useful
way to be angry and they they saw this
as them being opposed to one of the
other major schools of antiquity that
was the aristotelians Aristotle says and
and you know you can either read it in
the nick of McCain ethics or if you like
the you know Daniel Goldman and
emotional intelligence it's the first
first line in his book is a quote from
Aristotle Aristotle said that sometimes
we ought to get angry it's you know he
says it's not easy to figure out when we
should get angry how angry we should get
who the right people to get angry with
are but there are some cases Aristotle
thought where it's virtues to be angry
stoic said yeah that's that's a sign of
how off-based the aristotelians are
it's never a good thing they viewed it
as as something quite bad and
um they some of them even called it a
brief Madness
now they did take from the aristotelians
some insights that that they had and
they provided which is you know to think
about what anger is you know how do we
characterize it Aristotle said that
anger is a type of pain it is a painful
emotion which comes from perceiving that
another person has slighted us that
they've done us some some wrong they've
treated us as less than we deserve so
anger is connected up with conceptions
of right and wrong
Justice and Injustice fairness and
unfairness what I deserve and you know
there's a lot of ways in which this can
can go off the rails
um the the sliding doesn't have to be
actually real it could just be imagined
Aristotle says and the stoics think that
in most cases it's imagined it can not
only be against ourselves it can be
against other people that we're
concerned with or things we're concerned
with so you know if I'm really a
hardcore you know Apple Enthusiast which
I'm not I only use this because that's
what our you know we're an iPhone family
I'm not emotionally invested but if
somebody like you know starts running
down Steve Jobs and all that's what some
people really get worked up about that
don't they because they somehow they're
invested in in this we can get angry
about all sorts of things uh we get
angry about okay breakfast cereal we eat
um you know think about sports you know
oh you know we're here in Wisconsin
right I'm from Wisconsin so
I you know I have no compunction in
saying the Vikings suck right but try
that in Minneapolis and people might get
angry with you especially if you're in a
sports bar right
um and we could go on and on and on with
examples that that fit this now the
stoics
um went a little bit further they they
viewed anger
um well air some of this too anger is
not only a sort of pain it's also a
desire
and the stoics thought of it as a kind
of Desire too
a desire for what what is it that anger
wants
anger wants what the Greeks called
timuriya which means sometimes you
translate it as Revenge but it also
means retribution setting things right
you know when somebody is is treated you
badly you want things to be restored
that's why it's so important when you're
angry at somebody who you're close to to
get them to recognize that they did
something wrong when they treated you
that way or you want to set things right
you want to restore something
um
now in order to adequately understand
anger we want to focus on a couple
different aspects and here's where the
stoics start to become really useful one
is the causes of being why why do people
be calm and feel angry and then the
workings and the effects of anger and
then we can also talk about you know the
moral status of anger but like I said
the stoics see it as always bad
a question of how bad is it right if I
had some real anger problems I have a
vice established in my character that's
worse than like you know one person
losing their temper once in a blue moon
so causes of anger
whenever somebody gets angry from the
stoic perspective there's there's at
least one thing that's gone wrong
and it's gone wrong not only out there
in the world but on the part of the
person who is getting angry
and he says that as many people uh the
story say is many people understand
anger it arises when someone does
something wrong to someone else the
second person then feels upset they want
to retaliate and the retaliation this is
where it gets really interesting that
retaliation that that Tim erase us is
understood as something good
is it something good in a way it is
because it's setting things right
but it only works to set things right by
being something that the other person
doesn't like if I get angry at you and
you um you know need your car washed or
something that when I go and I wash your
car that's a very unsuccessful way to be
angry and to show anger right I mean I
can do it passive aggressively you know
act like a jerk while I'm washing your
car or something like that but then it's
then we've got more than just car
washing going on
instead a key your car right or kick the
tires or or you know whatever who knows
you know there's lots of ways we can
express anger in terms of cars uh maybe
I just paired your car your pair of
socks you know it's no good
club okay the examples that we can give
are like infinite that we can all relate
to this so you know we want to impose
something and we say in this case
what's normally wrong is Right insulting
another person is normally wrong but if
somebody's you know screwed with us then
we get to do it to them
um in kicking somebody's car right uh
normally not a good thing to do uh it
becomes right punching somebody out
right we could go on and on and on with
this sort of thing now anger can arise
in a number of different ways
one one is when there there's a
perceived threat
um we have a typical response and part
of this is rooted in our body we talk
about the fight or flight response we
perceive a threat that can morph into
anger quite easily
um
when we when we perceive an injury to
ourselves whether physically or in terms
of our social status or other you know
we might say psychic things uh insults
harm contempt when somebody shows us
contempt they show that they don't think
very much of us
lack of care like forgetting people's
names classic example even when they
just get in our way
we can get angry at them Epictetus goes
so far as to say that competition can
even make us feel anger at other people
you've probably all seen this with with
you know Sports you know all of us
probably played some Sport and the other
person you know they're supposed to
compete with us all right that's the
whole point
of game is
this petition but but sometimes it can
become very very see the other person as
an obstacle and to get angry at them for
doing well
and that's you know that's pretty
irrational
anger arises in a number of ways from
getting a couple things mixed up
according to
so one of these is this fundamental
distinction between what is in our
control what's not in our control
when we think that things that are
out of our control are actually in our
control we're setting ourselves up for
getting angry
when we see things that are outside of
our control as where we ought to be
putting our desires
and you know where we ought to be
placing our aversions we're also setting
ourselves up for getting angry because
we don't control those things so if I
want
um like if I even if I want uh the
library to I don't know throw me a
birthday party
a silly thing to desire and I allow
myself to get really emotionally
invested in this and then my birthday
comes around and no party and I get
angry at the library for screwing with
me
um whose fault is it that's my fault I
should know that that's something
totally out of my control
um
anger also involves a couple other
things that the Stokes talk a lot about
perceptions and perspectives so the
stoics talk about appearances anybody
who's read epictetuses uh and critian he
talks a lot about what and how we should
react to appearances those are fantastic
those are things that literally sort of
impinge upon us and they can be what
they present themselves as being or they
can be quite different
so somebody you know in the grocery
store bumps into me with their cart
right now I
maybe I I have you know the impression
that they're trying to get me out of the
way so they can get to the good bananas
um and I want the good bananas
now there's probably some other things
going on there too what he calls
judgments you know dogmata some
projection onto reality of what's going
on but there's also the appearance you
know maybe I look at that person I'm
like that that person is probably a
banana uh connoisseur
I've got that impression well
I I don't have to allow that impression
to carry me away and get me angry but we
we do this and I picked a you know Silly
example but you could think of all sorts
of other things somebody bumps into you
uh as you're coming out the door and
knocks the stuff out of your hand
are they a jerk are they just making a
mistake how do we react a lot of times
we react very quickly and they become
angry we may be making a lot of
assumptions we may end up assenting to
things that we we don't need to and
here's what's really important though
Epictetus says that the person who gets
angry gets angry because it's their
anger seems like a rational response
it seems like it's what's befitting the
situation it may be totally off base but
there is a reasoning process involved
what's good about that is that means
that if we can reconstruct or catch our
reasoning process at work we have the
possibility of actually intervening and
doing something about it
now he they also talk about what anger
does so
and here's where the stoics have kind of
an interesting
I would say disagreement Seneca have any
of you read seneca's on anger
uh so I'm going to just summarize bits
of it for you it's well worth reading
it's quite quite astute but one of the
things that Seneca does seem to think is
that once we actually begin once we have
become angry there's nothing we can do
about it
we're totally irrational reason has
gotten sucked into this you know desire
this passion and it's only going to be
used to try to figure out how to how to
you know get our revenge or do something
else instead
Epictetus seems to be much more
optimistic about our capacity to
intervene
um so it's debatable the extent to which
once a person's angry he or she can have
any reflection or resistance or rational
control it is clear that anger does
subvert our rationality we are thinking
when we get angry most of the time I
mean there is like the blind rage I
don't know if I have energy ever been in
that I have that's terrible because
you're not even thinking you're just
trying to like hurt somebody or destroy
some
that's that's really you know almost
inhuman but most of the time we're
actually thinking but we're we're
thinking along lines that are not uh
conducive to our good to to you know say
having a good relationship with a spouse
or a boyfriend or girlfriend right we
could understand the good that's at
stake we might not follow out what our
anger leads us to we think about things
like what's the best way to go on the
attack
or we think about we start going through
reasoning processes of hey what they
said right now they've been saying that
for a long time they've been engaging in
that crappy Behavior towards me for a
long time we go through those sorts of
things
um
the other things that anger does
Seneca says anger makes us resistant to
the truth
we think that we have the truth but when
we're confronted with the truth then he
says Seneca says anger gets angry at the
truth itself if truth seems to
contradict its desire
it also makes us and this is another
effect and it makes us very hasty
how many of you have this experience
when you get angry things kind of speed
up in your head and things need to be
settled right now you need to say this
thing to this person you know somebody
will say maybe sleep on it don't don't
fire off that email right away that
email should never be sent to anger
right right they last forever
you know the other person can say look
at this thing that you wrote
uh you should put it in the drafts
instead right but anger tells us no I
need to do something right now and this
is something they were noted back in
ancient times Epictetus also suggests
that anger makes us in a certain sense
more like animals it removes from us our
our distinctively human capacities and
makes us like beasts of prey
um this is a good place I've thrown a
lot of information and sort of take a
pause and any questions or comments we
can engage in a little bit of discussion
then we'll talk about some techniques
that these guys had for how to deal with
your outing
yeah
everything has two sides what is what do
the stuff says
yeah oh that's where it gets really
interesting there are none none
whatsoever
um and that's what makes them so extreme
um I and again I I don't actually agree
with them entirely about
um their view on anger that it's never a
good thing I'm more of a centillion I
think that some of their techniques can
be useful for addressing our anger but
they have they really are zero tolerance
when it comes to
um Seneca considers and so does
Epictetus but Seneca does in this book
on anger he considers some of the common
arguments at the time for why angry
might be useful like um well it's good
for when you gotta fight right you gotta
stand up against Injustice he says well
you could do that with reason too
you know and anything that you can do
with with anger you can do by telling
yourself this is the right thing to do
and I can do it without passion you can
do it more reliably you can make sure
that you'll actually follow through on
it because anger is quick to make all
sorts of promises another thing that he
talks about is um
you know anger can sometimes be
people think that it can be useful I
actually do
that to convey the impression that I'm
serious I mean I shout you know uh
well let's say I'm I'm I've got a bunch
of students that are not taking their
assignments seriously and I slam my hand
down and I say damn it this is important
stuff you need to get those rough drafts
to me by the end of the week right now
some of the students might oh Savage man
I better get this done right
um
Seneca says
that would only be okay if you're not
actually feeling anger but you're
pretending to be here it's not like a
judge for example and handing down a
sentence probably should yell at the guy
because you know
the criminal who's been condemned
because uh that's going to get through
hopefully but the judge himself
shouldn't feeling
if he does then it's it's not a good
thing right yeah
so what do you think about that do you
buy it or yeah I I I like this I buy
this I also see anger as a motivator for
us yeah motivates you to do things
[Music]
yeah okay and again the stoics they all
they they only they think it only has
negative yeah it's it's sort of like um
whatever positive outcomes might come
out of it you're taking the risk of
things really going off the rails by
introducing anger rather than trying to
do it another way so sort of like saying
we're going to do something vicious
in order to promote virtue
there's something inherently
contradictory about it for the stoics I
would say
any other questions or counts
let's talk about techniques then so
um one of the things I do like about the
stocks is although they do think that
anger is bad
and they do say some pretty you know
funny things about angry people they're
not they're not overly moralistic
they're not you know doing an awful lot
of condemning people for getting angry
it's seen as sort of you know this is a
this is a bad thing to befall you to to
become angry Epictetus actually says
that our our response to an angry person
uh instead of getting angry at that we
probably should feel pity for them uh if
we're going to feel any sort of emotion
towards us now for the stoics
what we can do
is make use of our capacities for
reasoning and reflection the rational
faculty on the one hand and for our our
capacity for choice for determining
ourselves on the other we can bring
these to bear on the emotion of anger in
a lot of situations and and they give
advice about you know what to do when
you first start getting angry what to do
when you're angry what to do after
you've been angry screwed some things up
you know these are all things we're
thinking about and they also talk about
couple as well
what to do before we actually get angry
when we're heading into situations where
we should probably be on our guard and
realize we're liable to get angry so one
of the things we can do that they talk
about quite a bit is we can remind
ourselves that appearances are not often
what they claim to be so
you know it may appear to us that
somebody has slighted us but that may
not be the case at all and we can remind
we have to choose to do this it's not
something automatic to us as a matter of
fact what's more automatic is getting
angry at accurate on that right but we
can actually make a deliberate effort to
say hey I don't really know all the
facts of the case maybe I'm not going to
trust this appearance right away not
just what's been done but what motive
the person has we can take ownership for
our assumptions
we can also apply this distinction
between what's in our control and what's
not in our control that's very important
from a stoic perspective to get this
distinction right in the first place to
to see that again I'll sort of remind us
of something that I think we probably
all know for the stomachs what really is
in our control is our feelings our
thoughts our judgments the stuff that's
interior our social reputation we can we
can do things to screw it up
um but it's not really in our control
it's really a matter of other people and
what they choose to do whether we're
wealthy or poor again it's not that we
shouldn't be good money managers
it's not totally in our control
the health of the body the way the body
looks you know those of us who are
getting older know that you know you
don't have much I mean you can dye your
your hair if you want
you want it's going gray and white what
are you going to do right
there's a lot of things that are not in
our control other people's views you
know we can influence them we can try to
change what other people think but we're
often unsuccessful because it's really
up to them
so first we want to get that distinction
right and apply it then we can realize
that we're making ourselves vulnerable
to feeling hurt or wrong or hindered
when we treat things that are not in our
control as if they were there's there's
two things to say about this one is that
before we get angry we often do this we
act as if especially when we you know
we're particularly anxious about
something or when we're particularly
happy and hopeful about something
something seems to be going right
we invest a lot of emotion into
something that's out of our control like
you know oh I'm going to go out on a
date with so and so everything's going
to go so wonderful to get up in a very
glowy and all that and then you know
they call it cancel
or the date doesn't go so well
or you know on and on and on with these
sort of examples I'm going to get a
great book out of the library
and it turns out the book is uh pretty
boring
get mad at the author of the library or
whoever recommended the book and and uh
go on and on the other thing to remember
is that um
anger tends to make us feel like we're
more in control than we are
so it tends to make us think that all
sorts of things out there are actually
in our control once we're becoming so we
can remind ourselves of that and
hopefully uh you know
catch ourselves when we're doing that
um
Epictetus also says that
when we get angry at the things another
person does even wrong things
this isn't understandable but it's an
unreasonable response
so he uses for example somebody comes in
Epictetus doesn't have a lot of stuff
somebody steals his his nice little lamb
grassland
one of the few things that he has
and now he could get really mad because
you know who likes a thief he uses
thieves as examples a lot I guess
there's a lot of stealing going on back
at this time
at the bath at your place you know
um even talks about servants you know
always stealing a little bit you know
you got to sort of chalk up that they
call it shrinkage right and the retail
trade there's always going to be some
shrinkage going on
um now why does a thief steal
well because to that person that appears
to be what they ought to be doing it
doesn't make it right doesn't mean that
we should you know automatically say
well whatever they do is okay for them
we can recognize it as being wrong
sometimes they can even think yeah this
is doing something wrong and I like
doing wrong things to other people
because I like hurting people or the
world screwed me over so I'm going to
stick it to everybody else
there is a reasoning process there they
they are you know um doing the things
that they do not because at a
fundamental level there are just a bunch
of jerks but because they think that's
the right thing to do and the proper
response of Akita says like you
mentioned if you want to feel anything
he says in that case feel pity or
compassion allow us in Greek rather than
anger or gay or thumos
um and that that you know if we remind
ourselves of that that can be quite
helpful
Seneca also notes that it's kind of
silly to have the the Badness of uh or
error of the foolish person determine a
wise person's passion you know we can
remind ourselves that look if you're
trying to be you know intelligent
and you're going to get angry at any
time people screw up you're gonna be
angry all the time you're not going to
live a very happy life you're not going
to live the life of a wise person
and what we can do is we can make a
deliberate choice to follow reasons with
the way Seneca talks about it or to
maintain our faculty of choice in
accordance with nature so what we have
to do and and Epictetus gives examples
of this is uh
he talks about going to the bath now we
don't have you know we have public pools
if any of you go to public pools those
are you know sometimes it's fun
sometimes it's not right
um no you don't like it at all yeah
um and you know we think about movie
theaters right you go to the movie
theater
um somebody
up in your chair and back and somebody's
throwing popcorn you know kids do that
sort of stuff or we did when I was a kid
uh we were really rock kids
um you know people talk people are on
their cell phone Epictetus would say if
he was here in our time when you're
going to the movie theater expect that
sort of stuff
and you have a choice you can you can
tell yourself
you know I you can either say I came
here to watch a movie in total quiet and
calm with nobody messing with me or you
can say I came here to watch a movie but
also to keep my faculty of choice in
accordance with nature
this is more realistic actually that you
know to have these these expectations
that everything is going to go perfect
um you go to to a concert right I mean
that's one of the things you go to see a
band and people are jostling around
somebody's spilling their drink you know
these are the sorts of things that
happen Epictetus councils being very
realistic with ourselves and also
reminding ourselves what did I want to
do I wanted to make progress I wanted to
to keep we might say keep my cool
because that's part of maintaining my my
faculty of choice in accordance with
nature the other Stokes might talk more
in terms of virtue cultivating the
virtues Epictetus doesn't talk quite so
much about that but those are all very
useful techniques for dealing with our
own anger there's many more
stuff but I wanted to highlight those
yeah what's that sales
[Applause]
well uh like I said Epictetus doesn't
talk so much in terms of virtue as the
other stars do
he tends to talk about keeping your
faculty of choice in accordance with
nature but it's really the same thing
because the virtues are ways in which we
are disposed to act right and so the
stocks recognize four main virtues
wisdom
Justice courage and Temperance or
self-control
so so there are a couple interesting
things to say anger
one thing is
um
a lot of people mix up anger and courage
this is like you were talking about
people using anger for things right so a
lot of people said well you got to get
get them riled up and angry and then
they'll be courageous and Seneca says
look that's a terrible way to
train people because now you're just
going to give them an anger problem and
they're not going to have genuine
courage when they need it so we could
think of what do I what do I need to do
in order to really have fortitude of
courage or the capacity to deal with
adversity uh maybe it's not to get angry
maybe that that that requires something
some courage
self-control can play a role in it
if we think about some of the things we
get angry about
like if I get angry because somebody
took the last piece of cake right I'm
you know I'm not mortal he's become a
fat guy right so I didn't get this this
size by exercising a lot of temperance I
mean some people have you know an actual
issue and it's not their fault no I I
ate too much stuff you know I indulge
myself so if if I actually want to
develop Temperance uh
there's some things that I just can't
that
it's you know the last piece of cake I
probably don't need the last piece of
cake
maybe somebody else was who's skinny
does you you guys could use the last
piece of cake right and we could talk
also about Justice
um
you know anger has a tendency to make us
um think that we're behaving in a just
way when we're actually transgressing
Justice
and the stoics interestingly recognized
two modes of Justice this is in like
Cicero's on on duties at a couple other
places
they talked in terms of like justice in
the traditional sense of what we owe
each other you know
you and I are neighbors I shouldn't go
in your garage and take your stuff
without permission likewise you know but
then there's also benevolence or
sometimes the translator is Cherry you
know in the classic sense
this is going Beyond and being good to
other people well angers and anger is
sort of opposed to that and it's going
to interfere with that and when it comes
to wisdom
again anger is seductive it's sort of
like with courage right anger makes us
think that we fully understand the
situation that we get into
but we really become stupid when we get
angry
one of the best lines in an anger
workbook that I saw years ago was as
soon as you get angry just remind
yourself now you're stupid you know
that's really quite right and we can be
quite we can doesn't mean that we don't
think about stuff but there's something
missing in our reasoning process and you
notice that these cannot come together
right what's missing could be
attentiveness to the fabric of
relationships that I'm going to Rack by
calling somebody out and chewing them
out in front of everybody else
those could fit in with that so
so the virtues you know if we think in
terms of I want to cultivate these
virtues
that could be helpful in putting anger
into perspective it's tough to do though
it's it's you know and the virtues are
probably more helpful than saying I want
to keep my cry racist in a state in a
state of nature you know in accordance
with nature what we have to do is make
that concrete for ourselves
um sometimes it is in terms of like hey
I want to script my relationship with so
and so
I want to be able to look at myself in
the mirror tomorrow
all right well let's let's talk about
other people's anger that
so this is a pretty common experience
and even if you get your own anger under
control
there's a whole world of people out
there ready to get angry with you and
yell at you and slash retires and you
know filling your forms wrong at the DMV
or you know pick whatever you want so
um it's something we have to deal with
you know I think it's a little bit
tougher in our own time too because
we've made ourselves even more
vulnerable by participating in social
media
um as all of you have like Facebook or
Google Plus or Twitter or something like
that
how many of you have uh friends right
now mad at each other over the current
election
I'd say mean things to each other
I can't believe you possibly vote for so
and so
I mean I have some friends who are
really crazy
some of that stuff
calling for candidates to be
all sorts of terrible things to be done
and the people who vote for them
calling at you again some friends on the
left who are calling each other
counter-revolutionaries
you know and intimating that all I mean
they're not going to do anything these
are all academics
there's other people thank God but
they're getting pretty heated uh
now when when others get angry at us or
at other people we care about we can
often find ourselves having a lot of
emotional reactions one of them is fear
right that's a I think kind of a natural
response to seeing other people's anger
especially if it was very excessive it
can be kind of scary
others Among Us and I have to own up to
this often get angry in response uh
sometimes with with the who are you to
get angry at me over this
that's not going to be particularly
helpful so we want to
want to think about that
so that's another one
another one I think probably I guess you
could say trolls uh it would be Joy
right they get somebody angry that's
what they're looking for in the first
place
now Seneca makes a really interesting
observation I'm not sure he's correct
about this
entirely he says that anger is the only
Vice that can actually possess an entire
state of people
it can take it can you can take an
entire group and they can all be
animated by this this anger
um and we could we might want to think
about how culture feeds into anger and
can make it seem normal or how a society
can be one in which the members are
constantly getting angry with each other
I think there's you know we see a lot of
that going on especially in election
season I wish oh you know I suppose it's
always been like that in American
politics I you know I don't remember it
being this bad when I was younger but
there's always been some of that going
on
now what can we do
um
it's very important they say not to
allow ourselves to get angry with other
people in return now this can be very
difficult
because we can feel that by getting
angry with us they're doing something
wrong to us
like what like thinking badly of us
obviously they wouldn't be angry at us
if they thought that we were doing the
right thing
so they've already got a mistaken
impression of us and worse they're like
insulting us or calling us names or you
know raising their voice to us or
turning their back or being passive
aggressive and all these sort of things
are liable to make us angry
um now Seneca points out an Epictetus
pointed out that Passage
are we actually going to make anything
right by getting angry with those who
are angry with us
probably not
I mean it's it's likely that if they're
saying stuff to us they're not fully in
possession of their own mind they're in
the grips of anger and we're not going
to change their point of view in the
middle of an argument how many of you
ever have any of you ever really really
want an argument or
the person that you're arguing with says
you're totally right I'm really out of
line and I'm so sorry about all of this
I mean I've seen in movies
but I've never seen it in real life
[Music]
and but anger makes us think that we're
going to succeed in those sorts of
things so Seneca and epikita says it's
not useful to get angry and response so
what can we do
well we can we can tell ourselves
that the person who's getting angry is
getting angry because they got some
things wrong so if when we get angry
it's usually because we're getting some
things wrong it's the same thing for
other people and he uses the example of
Medea
you guys are all familiar with the
character Madea or from Greek tragedy so
when Dan was from colbius culcus is the
land of the Golden Fleece
and she was deuced
um by Jason Jason is the guy that Jason
the Argonauts the um really the
the uh
least heroic of the Greek Heroes he
needs he needs Hercules to come along
and fight his battles for him
um but it is a witch and she's also a
princess and she gives him the things
that'll allow him to steal the golden
piece
and so he takes her with him and she
even goes so far as the not just
betrayer family in that way but she
causes the death of her brother
so she's like totally you know burnt the
bridges
Jason takes her to to uh Greece and
things go pretty good for a while they
have some kids together
and then he decides that he is going to
improve his stance he's going to cement
the status of his own kids the sons that
he has
by
divorcing Medea putting her away
and marrying the local princess
now Madea takes us pretty bad she gets
very very angry she first tries to
reason with them and she says this is a
terrible thing you owe me look at all
the stuff it did for you and he's like
well you know because you're just not
understanding I mean this is I
understand that you don't like having to
go away but it's going to be good for
our kids and look it works out great for
everybody all around finally she gets
range and in her range she does one of
the things that um
establishes her as a
figure in Anger she she
sends along a shirt point or a dress of
it poisons the the bride to be that's
understandable right that people did
that sort of thing back then Hercules
got you know poison shirt himself it's
not nice but you know it's
understandable then she kills her kids
to kill their sons
and
then she presents Jason with this and
says see what you did
this is an euripid he's playing
so she is viewed as sort of a how you
know a good character for how far anger
can go and it's destructiveness and
people would go to the play and then get
ticked off at Medan what's wrong with
this lady you know when Aristotle talks
about catharsis and you know Greek
tragedy it wasn't just fear and pity it
was also anger that's being you know
affected by people you know like getting
angry at the figures on stage
appetitus says why are you so angry at
her first off it's a play you know it's
not it's not real life right
he says it's about a couple things but
um
why are you so angry with her he says
um
here yeah he says that she's a
a
noble and spirited Soul that's gone
drastically wrong
um she she's gone astray in her
reasoning she thinks that the
satisfaction of her passion of anger on
her husband at the expense of her
children is good and right when people
do things like that they're not doing it
because they think that it's the most
terrible thing in the world they think
this is the right thing for them to do
now again we can we can understand
without accepting or endorsing or you
know forgiving or excusing but we can
understand
so you know we can understand for
example that the things that people say
when they're angry stem from what Seneca
calls a temporary Madness and it doesn't
uh you know doesn't mean that they're
not hurtful or bad but we can understand
that perhaps the person doesn't mean
that
we don't have to take them to heart we
don't have to allow them into we have we
have control we have a choice there
um
when dealing with angry people another
thing that they suggest is don't make
commitments you know when people are in
arguments they often will make
commitments because they're going into
by the other person try not to make a
lot of judgments about the the other
person on the basis of when they're
angry because we're often quite
different when we're angry
um probably don't try to convince them
at the time even about whether their
anger is destructive out of control
because you're probably not going to
reach them and that's liable once you
start thinking that you yourself are you
know doing the right thing by doing this
and you're going to counsel them or help
them out with that now you're actually
probably
very concerned with things that are
totally out of your control
so you're placing yourself at risk for
getting angry yourself which is often
what happens in Anger Management right
the anger management therapist who's
usually somebody who has struggled with
anger themselves as a client the client
you know is angry and you know you talk
with them a bit and then after a while
you're like why can't I get through to
you yeah go well you've already lost now
right
you're you're not going to get through
that so um what can we do
well you know the stomach suggests that
we can try to accommodate ourselves
reasonably to others uh you know and try
not to give other people the occasion to
take offense that can be very difficult
to some people some people have a
tendency towards taking offense so it's
not always going to be possible but we
can treat them as if they're somebody
who's struggling with as they say an
illness the other thing that we can do
that's very important is um
stoics talk about the importance of
roles and relationships
so by virtue of say being a teacher I
have a certain role and a relationship
with my students applicator says our
duties can be understood by looking at
the roles that we have
so you know teacher to student is one
example all of us are children of
somebody many of us are parents of
somebody I think Brothers sister
neighbor all of these are names of rules
that we have it's very easy when we
become angry to lose sight of those
roles and those relationships and to
think you know
you know this person who normally I care
about or love or at least you know live
next to it doesn't you know bother me
that much is feared gain for for
whatever I want to do saying because I
feel um violated at the time I feel you
know you know slider I feel the urge to
Revenge myself what we can do is remind
ourselves hey I'm talking to my kid I'm
talking to my student I am talking as a
teacher to a student I want to not as
epicus don't destroy the teacher within
you
don't destroy the father
you have a choice about that and so this
is sort of like reminding ourselves that
we want to keep our cry racist in
accordance with nature
when somebody gets angry at us we can
remind ourselves of that fabric of
relationships